it's not a title liverpool ever wanted
the european capital of cancer
but cancer rates here are much higher
than anywhere else in the country
that's why there's so much demand for
services
like the sunflowers cancer charity
a lot of young people nowadays
are coming in with breast cancer vicky
underwent treatment for her breast
cancer but five years later it came back
and has now spread all over her body
and
it's incurable
i don't want to say the word but i've
got secondary breast cancer now in my
bones
so um
it's terminal and i'm on palliative care
now
i think i've got about 15 tumours now
throughout my body through my pelvis
three in my spine a little bit on my
skull me grandma died of breast cancer
yeah
so it's been quite hard for me mom
because she's seen
her mum die and now she's looking at me
and you know she can see that i'm you
know obviously i'm obviously not very
well
jillian became overwhelmed with anxiety
during her breast cancer treatment but
she was told there was a three-month
wait for counseling on the nhs
okay i'm fine now but what if what
happens next you know what if it comes
back and i've got young children you
know what happens if this doesn't work
emma says the city's high cancer rates
are driven by deepening health
inequalities
more than half of this city can expect
to have cancer in their lifetime a lot
of that's linked to poverty
cancer mortality in merseyside is 76
higher than the european average and
every year in liverpool around 40
percent of cancer cases are diagnosed by
doctors in a e
we're northwest cancer research we're a
local uh cancer charity the reason why
people from poorer communities might
present later or differ treatment
is because they don't expect to live
very long
their parents will have died at a
relatively early age they'll have
colleagues from work that might die at a
relatively early age you're talking
about people in their 60s yes that's
right
the government has pledged to tackle
health inequalities as part of its
battle against the killer disease
here in liverpool in the communities hit
hardest by cancer
that promise must be delivered
urgently
joshi sky news in liverpool